we're taking a look now at one of the
most important issues for many families
in this country how the pandemic has
affected the mental health of new
mothers a uk study found anxiety levels
are up 37 percent and depression rates
rather spike 30 percent in pregnant
women and new mothers during this
pandemic we spoke with monica ayers who
gave birth to her daughter nora in march
of 2020. now she's pregnant with her
second child and also ashanti hill was a
five-year-old daughter nova is her name
she is eight months pregnant they told
us this pandemic increased their anxiety
and their mom guilt
[Music]
i think that a lot of the support
systems that i anticipated weren't there
and one of the hardest things for me was
just the isolation and the loneliness
when i did find out i was pregnant it
wasn't really an issue
until the winter started to come and
cope with really started to ramp back up
again there's been a few moments during
this pregnancy
if i'm being honest that i wish to not
to be pregnant we're constantly having
to think about restrictions and how safe
is it for my fiance to be around others
and then come home so both fear and the
restrictions would be the reasons i went
through
a lot of depression just from feeling so
lonely because we were too scared to see
people definitely felt isolated my
fiance has always worked out of the
house but not being able to have like
friends come over and just kind of sit
with me and enjoy my pregnancy with me
or go over to their houses has
definitely affected us
[Music]
she was a spring baby which is great
because there was the option of seeing
people outdoors i had such anxiety i had
people sit 20 feet away and we just sort
of hold up the baby and you know that's
how my dad met his granddaughter was
from 20 feet across our yard i've
definitely felt guilty kind of
restricting our activities for myself my
family and my daughter i feel some
embarrassment about my anxiety because
it did become at one point so
debilitating that even when friends were
reaching out i just couldn't i couldn't
accept it
i am pregnant with my second child which
we're very excited about i think i feel
more hopeful this time this is almost an
opportunity for a do-over the pregnancy
group that i am in online has been super
helpful
because we're all going through the same
things together no matter how far along
in our pregnancy we are it's really nice
to just be able to just vent those of us
who became
his parents in the pandemic this is all
we know you know i have friends with
children who say they want to get back
to normal but i don't know what it's
like to be a parent not in a pandemic
psychiatrist dr catherine berndorf
specializes in reproductive mental
health at new york presbyterian wild
cornell medical center and joins us to
discuss we're so glad you're here today
to talk about this catherine yesterday
we had simone tate on from poppy seed
health she was talking about as she left
she said maternal health mental health
for women is one of the worst things in
this country that it's under reported
and nobody talks about it it seems like
you were saying the exact same thing
right and thank you guys for doing a
segment like this bringing attention to
something like this that's so important
and under-reported under-diagnosed and
thus under-treated because it's not a
one-size-fits-all what what are you
saying when when you're talking about
maternal mental health well i think it's
the idea around motherhood yeah right i
think that's motherhood is not a
monolithic experience right it affects
people very differently right it's a
life change and i don't think we think
about it that way we we sort of have
romanticized the idea of the baby it's
joyous it's natural and it's easy and no
problem but that's not how women feel
yeah the the popular narratives about
how you have the baby the whole birth
process and then the aftermath is very
romanticized and the only question you
really get if you're a new mom is like
are you over the moon yes you have to
say yes
it's pressure and maybe you want to say
so true i've asked that question many
times isn't this wonderful yeah i have
to catch myself sometime in my own
apartment building oh look at the baby
it's really like how are you what i mean
to be doing when i catch myself is to
look the mom in the eyes and say how are
you actually what's the reality what is
the right reality no i'm asking you oh
what is yeah
but you're right though
that's a good question what is the
reality the reality is it's complicated
that it's challenging and all that's
okay and it's okay it's absolutely fine
but what people don't get is that you
can be good and bad right you can be you
can love your baby and feel like this
might have been a regret like what did i
do yeah did i just ruin my life both
those opposing ideas are true at the
same time people don't know they can
hold that at once and be okay or or love
their your baby but also worry about
your identity at work
exactly i had my uh first child in my
early 20s and then my daughter in my
late 20s and as i got older i realized
what i didn't do during the first two
kids um so the question i want to ask
for all the men that are out there
whether you're a husband a father to a
daughter who is pregnant or a brother to
a sister who is pregnant what can we do
that is my favorite question to ask
because often times when a segment like
this pops on tv the man will casually
walk by and say well that has nothing to
do with me they're not talking oh no
well you know what guys let me get my
camera real quick we are talking to you
to all the men out there you can help
you can assist you can make these women
feel better absolutely most importantly
is to pay attention and to ask
how your you know your wife is or your
partner how are you what can i do for
you
you don't look yourself
let me help you you are the advocate
right you are the advocate we all need
them and sometimes when we're feeling
our worst we cannot ask for help so
here's the key point though everything
is normal and acceptable and part of the
game but there is a point at which it's
just not enough to handle it at home you
need some intervention or help what is
that point how do you know great
question so when are you over the line
right so when is it too much and i think
right now in this pandemic everyone's
kind of over the edge right but when
you're not functioning in your regular
life when the stress is too much and
it's really impacting you on a daily
basis then you're in another category
then you move from you know anxiety a
little bit of anxiety particularly for
new moms i mean it's darwinian we have
to protect the baby right you should be
a little anxious but too much of of that
is not okay so it's when you're can't
stop thinking thoughts are going round
and round in your head or you or you
don't want to get out of bed but you're
or you're going through the motions of
life or things are feeling bleak and
it's just not
it's not what it should be not for a day
but for a little while a few days to a
week you start to wonder to yourself i
mean everyone has a bad day of course
but if it goes on for more than a few
days in in a in a week or two you're
looking at something else okay dr
katherine berndorf thank you so much
these conversations are valuable so we
appreciate you coming by